-Our first guest tonight
is a Tony and Emmy-winning actor
who spent eight years hosting
"The Late Late Show
with James Corden."
His new interview show,
"This Life of Mine..."
premieres February 1st
on Sirius XM Stars channel 109
and the Sirius XM app.
Please welcome back to the show
our good friend
James Corden, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, James.
-Hi. How are you?
-Welcome back to the States.
Welcome back to
a talk-show studio.
-I know.
-You got out of the life.
-I did.
-I did. And you can, too!
-I do -- I do --
-That's all I'm doing.
I went to see Jimmy last night.
I'm gonna go and see Stephen
in a minute.
And I say, "Listen. You don't...
I know they make you feel
like you've got to do this."
-I gotta do it.
-You don't!
-I gotta do it tomorrow,
and then we gotta do it
the next day!
-Oh, that's -- that's the thing.
You realize.
-How much more time do you have
in your day, James?
-Oh. Oh. There's a -- Yeah.
But that can have -- That's
a double-edged sword, you know.
Then I've got time
to really contemplate
and go to quite a dark place.
-When you're keeping busy...
-I've not been doing anything,
in truth.
I really --
I really decided to --
We were so conscious,
my wife and I,
that we were moving.
You know, we have three kids.
They're 12, 9, and 6.
And to take them -- to lift
them up from Los Angeles
and be back in London --
For me then to leave
would be --
and to go off
and do anything else would be --
would be, you know,
such a stupid decision.
So all we've been doing --
all we've been doing
is just really
just focusing on trying to --
We knew we were going to
hit bumps along the way.
That was inevitable.
but to try and make them
as soft as we could for them,
really.
That was the biggest thing.
-You were well-known in the UK
before you came over here
to do your show,
and then very quickly
you became well-known here.
When you went back to the UK,
had they been familiar
with the work
you were doing over here?
Did "The Late Late Show"
make a mark?
-Well, they --
I suppose because, you know,
we came up -- we had a couple of
clips or segments that would --
that would do very well online
and stuff, so they knew that.
But nobody --
Because back at home in Britain,
no one does a talk show
every night of the week.
-Yes.
-So, like, Graham Norton,
which is the biggest talk show
in the country
and was a huge influence on me
and the way
that we built our show
is on once a week for, I think,
30 weeks of the year.
And that is exactly
how it should be done.
-I mean...
I'm so jealous of him.
-Nobody -- Nobody can comp--
Nobody at home would comprehend
because I'd be like, "Well,
no, because I'm doing a show."
And they were,
"You just did it yesterday."
I go, "Mm-hmm. Yeah, no, no.
I know. I'm..."
"What are you doing?"
"It's essentially the same,
just with different people.
That's it. It's a long
fever dream really."
-Also, the other thing
I'm so jealous --
Every time you see
Graham Norton,
it's four of the most famous
people in the world.
-Yes.
-He always -- His guests are --
Any one of us
would kill ourselves
to have all of his guests
on one show.
-Because he's doing it once
a week for 30 weeks of the year.
So it's like -- It's all of
those -- Yeah, there's like --
Look, if you were doing this
once a week,
I don't make the cut here.
I'm not here. Not a chance!
-Oh, absolutely not.
-Not a chance!
I'd be waiting outside hoping
that there's some awful bout
of gastric flu or something,
and then I might
just get on down.
-Hanks went down. Bad news.
Hanks went down.
Good news. Corden's outside.
-Correct.
-Yeah.
-Bradley --
Bradley Cooper slipped.
Don't worry. Bring in --
That's it.
So, you know, at this moment,
I'm very grateful
that you do it every day.
-Yeah.
Well, thank you. I'm grateful.
Look. I'm grateful to have you.
How about -- Obviously so
well-known in both places.
What is the difference
between how you're approached
by people in LA
versus how you're approached
by people in London?
-Well, you don't -
You don't really get approached
by anyone in LA.
Because, firstly, you're not
walking anywhere
-Right.
-You're just in a car
and then you're in a valet.
But, also, even if
you're in a restaurant,
you know, you're aware --
If you live in Los Angeles
and you host a show at 12:35
in the morning on CBS,
you know where you are
in the food chain.
-Yeah.
-You know, like,
Oprah was in here yesterday.
They actually look at you
with disdain.
You know what I mean? Like,
"Oh, it's you. Oh, my God."
Like that.
But in the UK, I, um --
I wrote a TV show
that not many people
would ever know.
I wrote a TV show,
"Gavin & Stacey," which --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ohh.
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm watching right now.
Right now you're like,
"I should be getting residuals!"
-Hang on. Are you --
Are you British?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Are you? Are you?
Whereabouts are you from?
-Kent!
-Kent? Look out, guys.
Be careful. That...
Whereabouts in Kent?
-Chatham.
-Oh, they're thieves.
They are thieves.
Aw! I love that you're here!
-Also, don't come here
and now start the expectation
that I'm gonna do crowd work.
We'll have people showing up.
They're going to go crazy
every time they hear
where they're from.
-No. So I did this show
called "Gavin & Stacey,"
which, to everybody's
surprise -- mostly me and my --
Me and my best friend Ruth
Jones, We wrote it together.
And so, really, more often
than anything else,
people will come up to me
and they'll say catchphrases
from that show.
Can you remember a catchphrase?
-"What's occurrin'?"
There you go.
That's what people
will say to me all the time.
Or more often than not, they'll
come up to me and they'll ask --
Because the last episode
ended on a proposal.
And they will ask,
"Did Smithy say yes or no?"
Which I will never share.
-What is the -- What is the
catchphrase? "What's the..."
-No, it's --
Well, the show is set in, uh --
Um, Sirius XM
are going to be so pleased
that we're talking about --
The show is set in a small town
out just outside of London,
in Essex called Billericay, and
an island called Barry Island,
which is in Wales,
just outside of Cardiff.
And in Barry, they've got
a very particular accent.
It's sort of like that. Right?
And you say,
"Oh, what's occurrin'?"
-Oh. "What's occurring?"
I got you. Got it.
-She'd say,
"Oh, what's occurrin'?"
And that's where that came from.
-Alright.
-Yeah.
-So, uh, maybe watch that
instead of the XM show?
What do you think?
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, look.
I get -- I get --
I get paid for the attempt, man.
-I have a lot. We're gonna --
The next segment
is gonna be all Sirius XM.
We'll be right back with James.